I love this guy and I'll tell you why
I'll tell you why though watching your
blogs and the things that you put out
and your enthusiasm for this film you
would sell me No thank you and I'm
saying that because as a star train you
rep the Star Wars fans yeah what is it
about Star Wars before you're involved
in it that makes you love it the way
Star Wars fans do I always was sensitive
to imagination and I was always
sensitive to stories that one about my
circumstance but they still had a
relatable sense of humanity in it and
Star Wars for me represented that and I
was always the kid who would walk you
know in the streets and think what if
this happened what if that happened
there will all be mr. cool fantasy stuff
and and - and to have Star Wars and to
have a group of people who have serious
dialogue about it I felt like I was part
of a big family and from then I've just
been a pinnate big fan well now you are
one of the family oh yeah and that's the
crazy part where it just all goes crazy
I've heard you say about Finn that he is
very unique he's different than anyone
we've seen in Star Wars yeah you can't
tell me obviously why but why because I
think I think for me this is the first
time we've had a real stormtrooper
someone who is is a stormtrooper by a
definition take off his helmet and we
were going into his individuality we've
always seen stormtroopers we see them
like you know masses of obese and they
all come in do their thing and they go
but to go to one stormtrooper to look at
his circumstance and to discover his
mind and mentality is it's so different
to me and for me it's like in force
awakens I'm wearing a stormtrooper suit
I would get to wear a rebel jacket I get
to wield a lightsaber I get a blast I
work with Han Solo and Shuba I get to do
everything
goosebumps everything so for me it's
like I let you go want to give you
Fandango
has he special made force awakens movie
gift cards for you what does this get me
do I get to get going good come on
little bit see this
[Music]
you